fpc it's a word or i guess an initialism
that a whole lot of people who geek out
on poi tethers are super excited about
and now it's available with the most
popular poi in the world
pod poi do the tethers elevate the
venerable pod poi do they bring a host
of cool tech to an old favorite
i'll share my thoughts with you drex
here from drexfactor poi sharing with
you the love of poi spinning and flow
arts to benefit your body and brain and
today i want to talk about the latest
update to the most popular poi ever
released but before i do i want to give
a quick shout out to the friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
muchinski and becca beklin thank you all
so very much for your support from my
work and my mission
so pod poi in case you didn't know are
sets of led poi made by emeryville
california-based prop maker flow toys
they're also kind of a big deal they are
easily the most popular and ubiquitous
brand of poi out there in the world and
have been now for a decade i actually
did a whole video talking about why they
were such a revolutionary product that
i'll go ahead and link to down in the
description as well as up in the cards
if you're watching on youtube pod poi
were groundbreaking but also definitely
a product of their time in many ways
most notably in their tethers and
handles since the mid-2010s thicker and
stiffer rope tethers have been
increasingly in demand driven in large
part by the popularity of poi juggling
and advancements in techniques around
throws and contact in particular a type
of rope called vpc became super popular
among this set of poi spinners vpc
stands for vectrin polyolefin core it's
a type of rope that is popularly used in
sailing and it somehow manages to strike
a balance between being flexible and
supple enough to spin in most classic
poi tricks as well as stiff enough to
help with juggling and other related
throws but it's also difficult to cut
and modify so traditionally it's been
the domain of dedicated people who were
willing to find workarounds or hacks
that would make the rope usable but
flowtoys has now created its own
variation on this material called
fpc and yes i checked the f does indeed
stand for flow toys this variation on
vpc is made with a different core
material that can be easily melted so
changing its length and modifying it is
far easier than it would be for vpc
itself and this means they're now
marketing the most popular poi in the
world with a native solution for those
thicker tethers the good people at
flowtoys sent me a brand new pair of pod
poi with those fpc tethers to play with
review and make flow videos with and
i've now had a few months to put them
through their paces so now i want to
share my thoughts on them with you by
the way if you're new here please make
sure to like and subscribe so you get to
see more videos from me in the future i
make lots of content around poi spinning
and flow arts so if you like this video
i think you'll probably like some of my
other videos too but back to the review
now please note the electronics inside
the poi haven't changed at all so this
isn't going to follow my standard review
rubric if you'd like to know my thoughts
on the features ease of use etc you can
check out my old review of the capsules
2.0 i'll link to that down in the
description as well as up in the cards
if you're watching on youtube this is
going to be more a smorgasbord of my
thoughts around the new tethers it's
less structured than my usual reviews
and is going to focus more on feel than
anything else so let's dive in so to
start many of us will likely remember
that flow toys did actually offer their
poi with thicker tethers already
once upon a time you could get your pod
poi with fatty flow cord and i still
stand by these being the softest and
most comfortable tethers that i've ever
used
but they also never really caught on and
tastes have definitely moved beyond that
era and even those of us who were fans
of the fatty flow cord knew that as
hardware they didn't really match up
seamlessly to pod poi
the end didn't feel comfortably into the
housing for the capsules and it was a
royal pain to get the heads to fully
close around them so with the fpc being
a lot stiffer than fatty flow cord
flowtoys has addressed that problem with
two modifications to their classic pod
poi hardware the first is that the hole
that the tether comes out of in the
capsule has been enlarged so now it's a
comfortable diameter for the tethers the
second is that the ring used to hold the
entire housing in place has a bigger
hole to allow thicker tethers through so
like one quick note here
the width of each of these petals in the
pod assembly hasn't really increased so
now when you close them up there are
gaps between them that don't close all
the way and this means that if you
really get cooking at high velocity
while you're spinning them there will be
a noticeable whistling sound as you
spend them
i learned to tune it out pretty quickly
but your mileage may vary cool so with
that ground covered let me tell you some
things that i like about these new
tethers so these tethers are clearly
great for throws in addition to
presenting a bigger target to catch and
stiffer tethers that flop around less as
they're thrown these tethers have a good
amount of friction without being very
abrasive that's a difficult balance to
strike i've also found they're really
good for gunslingers the stiffer tethers
make spiral wraps easier to maneuver and
tethers with more girth give you more to
hold onto with gunslingers in general
this actually kind of caught me by
surprise but it was a welcome bonus they
also turned out to be fantastic for a
glow stringing technique that i've been
pulling over into my poi dancing work of
late shotguns the more rigid tethers
help absorb the momentum of the poi as
you wrap them up in your hands
these are super easy to get to a full
stop and they don't jiggle once you do
it also has to be said that these
tethers are great for the same reason
that i was using fatty flow cord for
years they show up really really well on
camera if you've ever been through the
torture of trying to pull a still from
your video for a thumbnail and edit out
the background around smithy smithyrope
you know that it is a special kind of
hell
not only do the fpc tethers show up
better on video they also make this kind
of editing substantially easier what is
that not a common problem
all that said there are some things
around these tethers that aren't my
personal cup of tea but your mileage on
these points may vary i think my biggest
gripe is just that for trying to move us
into territory where the tethers are
easier to adjust they're still not as
easy as smithy rope when i want to
change the weight of my handles or even
trade out a new set of them entirely on
pod poi with smithy rope all i have to
do is untie the knot in the handles do
my business and re-tie the knot when
done
with the fpc rope i have to cut off the
end of the tether and then re-melt it so
i lose a little bit of length every time
i want to make a change
it's a bit more of a pain and it
discourages experimenting with different
weights and handle types now all that
said a whole lot of folks that focus on
poi juggling and tosses dial in their
handles with as little weight as
possible and then just leave them so
it's not going to be a deal breaker for
them now how about we talk about visual
profile now i think it has to be said
that these tethers are a perfect
complement for flo moji poi that is the
capsules 2.0 put inside of emojo spheres
from lanternsmith this setup has an
absolutely perfect balance and just
feels really satisfying in many ways and
part of the reason for that is that even
with thicker tethers i think we're kind
of used to having poi heads be
significantly wider than the tethers
that connect to them
most of the tech poi of the past decade
has been created with that specific
aesthetic principle in mind but things
are a little different when the tethers
and heads have a more similar diameter
though
this gets us more into territory where a
set of poi have a visual profile more
akin to sock poi now there's nothing
wrong with sock poi at all but you do
have to be conscious of the different
visual profile that they have
for instance people who primarily use
sock poi tend to stick with more
traditional poi styles heavily based in
body tracers and avoid things like plane
breaks or rapid stalls because even
minor errors in plane definition become
exaggerated when the tether is more
visible now to my eyes the fpc chord
starts taking pod poi towards the sock
poi side of the spectrum and a little
bit away from the visual profile of
contact poi
again
nothing wrong with sock poi and these
pod poi are really sitting in the middle
ground between the two
but it's a helpful thing to keep in mind
for choreographing with sets of these
one final point here the tethers were
longer than my usual taste when i got
them so i trimmed them down which is
actually a good thing because it's part
of what they're meant for and it gave me
a chance to try that out now this went
without complications for one of the
tethers but the other one started to
fray just slightly close to the handle a
little bit after that
i'm not sure if i missed a step here or
whether you should proceed with some
caution in general around cutting these
i'll keep my eye on this tether in the
long term to see if the fraying
drastically impacts its usable lifespan
or long-term comfort okay so the big
question do i like the tethers am i
going to keep on using them are they an
improvement of any kind on other tether
options
i'm going to give a qualified yes with
some caveats in my experience if you're
not doing a lot of poi juggling or
contact poi the benefits to tethers like
this
are kind of marginal it's definitely
more comfortable to use thicker tethers
overall you'll wind up with less wear
and tear on your finger calluses and
likely have a bit more direct control
over the movement of the poi themselves
but if you're hard up for cash or just
starting your flow journey it's a 10
difference between the smithy rope and
the fpc rope
it's not a big gap but again if you're
not doing a lot of tosses or contact or
you're not doing a lot of video or
photography intensive work then i don't
think you're going to notice a huge
difference between the two options on
the other hand you're eager to get into
contemporary tech poi and want the
security and satisfaction of working
with a company that has a proven track
record and a great warranty system then
your time has arrived my friend snag a
pair and take great joy in them as for
me i am probably going to continue to
use these as they are a good fit for my
current style of spinning and they're
going to make my life easier in making
video thumbnails but i'm also likely to
keep using my older sets with the smithy
rope 2.
both are good pod poi version 2.0 with
fpc tethers are available over at
flowtoys.com for
149.95 a pair
if you order a pair please use my promo
code that is
drexfactor2022 with no special
characters at all at checkout that gets
you a discount on your order and it
helps out the channel so everybody wins
[Music]
what do you think of the fpc tethers on
pod poi are they everything that you've
dreamed of and more are they an
incremental update to a classic product
leave me a comment and let me know this
video would not be possible if not for
the wonderful support of all of these
amazing people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you are
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of rewards and
help me out in my mission do check that
out please and thank you thank you so
much for watching friend if you'd like
to check out more of my flow product
reviews i will leave a link to a
playlist of video reviews that i have
done down in the description as well as
up on screen if you are watching on
youtube the youtube algorithm also
thinks that you'll like this top video
based upon your viewing habits so maybe
give that a look too make sure to get
outside and flow today and i'll see you
with a new video on wednesday
peace